in everyone talks about that transition
from Virginia to Iowa State how more how
much more explosive he was offensively
because of his style and play
Philadelphia having its way on the
offensive end to start this game they
are 5 of 7 from the floor here's a look
at Carson Edwards hitting from deep
played six games with the Celtics last
year as a matter of fact Edwards deep
rage and showing it off
tonight at 22 as we creep under three
minutes to go first quarter and a steal
off a bad turnover unable to control it
though Sheldon Mac nice save on the
baseline by Edwards a lot of work going
on at the legal office but Austin what
we can talk about is where the team
moves forward and we'll start with the
youth since that we're watching in front
of us those two franchises is a good
parking spot depends who's the home team
right gonna be on a roster but it's a
great opportunity of late-stage against
Carson a trans fed job cutting off that
rescreen he's so low to the ground he
what do you have to work out for someone
try to be in the gym knowing that you're
getting ready to play your first game
two and a quarter inches the highest on
record ever at the NBA Draft Combine he
shot
74 percent from the field for his career
that's for collegiate years that is also
an NCAA record day that he does man and
he protects and rim and I tell you when
he gives post up position you give him
the ball he knows what to do with it
waters off on the three it comes out to
Ray the cellie swap that shot away on
the other at a steal by Green who steps
in he's in traffic down to waters
trailer his Harrison's just knocked down
the free he'll hit two in a row
and robber wins it's up there to grab
that one Reba
Carson Edwards no hesitation awakening
Weymouth Eve christyn Williams person
Edwards rather a prolific College scorer
he said it we had John Beilein a couple
of days ago he said this kid's gonna
lead the team and I guess this is
because they've been here in Vegas
they've gone to shoe shows together the
bond is increasing and as you heard
Larry Nance at halftime they're all here
having their valuable quality time and
the chemistry is something that you
cannot want to pitch and got the crowd
going here
swindler off on the three lead at 16 to
make an 18th Boston on the road it's
Edwards with the finish
taco fall now a dozen points on a
perfect five for five shooting night
Edwards breaks away that's the closest
up into one all week or something about
you know shows no pool no gambling this
is the show right here on Nicola
changing the angles just doing little
subtle things the way he reacts Williams
with the layup at the other end at
Wisconsin Green Bay Edwards inside this
guy has a bucket he is a human bucket
folks what a Brad say just goes with
landok son Player of the Year back in
2018 the Florida Gulf Coast normally
jump City Edward
inside Welsh fast knocked away
Zen burn big trouble Edwards it's
trouble when he's got it
Bing and he's gonna work at it will see
this Carson Edwards kid Ryan I know
you're back I mean he has been a bucket
man when he's been out there and as you
see they're getting guys involved too
[Applause]
just a slight differential game and shot
clock as Edwards soars in for two Tom
all right good setup from Edwards and
the three from grant Williams already
seen six plays bio giddy oh hey now
[Applause]
corner three is one hundred million
dollars for the V Foundation so thank
you for your support
wrestler it says but I can't find in the
records so we know we've learnt two
things about you today you're a little
forgetful you left your credential on as
we came on camera and you are adept at
reading Wikipedia terrible
you didn't think when that news broke on
Thursday night you could tell just as he
put that up he was thinking where tako
flaw was and rolled it over the basket
how about that move to get to the bucket
by Edwards on a cut he's dropped one
pass on a couple of dribbles two
Porter's he plays I said it earlier he
plays with his chin up a lot of guys in
this league who have and I'm not trying
to defend what he did the other night
because I was with you and Ryan the
whole way but there are a lot of guys in
this league who have been agitators and
have made a living off of a plaintiff or
a couple of occasions but he played on
20 now that's chasing a basketball dream
if you're gonna play 22 teams amaze me
with New Orleans is 2010 Edwards gets
the best he got 14 that's the same way
nice passing great catch that was not an
easy catch for a big guy rolling down
the lane as quickly as it was a
six-point game delete his tan again
Edwards cleared some space and that's
all they needs pan last year with the
produced staffs Micah Shrewsbury who was
his assistant coach is now back at
Purdue so they know Carson Edwards well
turned into an easy basket for Bruno
Cibola Edwards what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content